Emme peas are choosing the three  finalists for the 2017 Sahara Prize for  freedom of thought the award honors  individuals defending human rights and  fundamental freedoms lawmakers are  expanding data protection to include new  means of communication such as whatsapp  it will also make it easier for users to  accept and refuse cookies Parliament  beefs up its anti dumping law to protect  EU jobs and industries from unfair  competition under new rules labor and  environmental standards of manufacturers  will be scrutinized lower quality food  products are being sold in some EU  states despite identical packaging and  branding Parliament and the Commission  discussed consumer protection laws MEP  is are looking into reports that  Monsanto is behind some of the  scientific reviews of one of its own  products a potentially carcinogenic  herbicide  [Music]